MIHAI IONESCU: Hello.
My name is Mihai Ionescu.
And I'll give a quick
introduction to monetizing web
games and applications.
Lately we have seen some
amazing growth in the
popularity of online games.
And this is a great opportunity
for developers to
take advantage of
this strength.
Notably, the fastest growing
segment using game
monetization is the freemium
model, where the game is free
but you charge for advanced
functionality.
Such games are successful
because they are designed to
offer the users a simple, true
In-App experience and are
monetizing using
micro-payments.
When considering the payments
API that meets those
characteristics, please
have a look at
Google In-App Payments.
It comes with a lot
of benefits.
First, for developers, the
pricing model is the most
aggressive in the industry,
5% flat fee.
The API is very simple, with
minimal integration steps.
And it also comes with full PCI
compliance, which means no
need to worry about complex
credit card regulations.
Similarly, users get a true
In-App experience, which means
purchasing with just
a few clicks.
Also, they get one payment
account to use across all
their games and applications
and private payment
credentials, which means no
need to worry about credit
card fraud or identity theft.
As I said earlier, users
want simplicity.
And with In-App Payments they
get simplicity when they make
a transaction, click,
pay, and use.
Similarly, developers want
simplicity in implementation.
With In-App Payments they get to
monetize in just two calls,
one API call to launch a
transaction and one API call
to collect.
To summarize In-App Payments,
it's about
simplicity on all fronts.
You don't need to worry about
risk management, compliance,
and analytics.
It is all taken care of
by the Google payments
infrastructure.
You also don't need to
worry about access to
a large user base.
With In-App Payments you have
access to a lot of users from
different Google properties such
as the Chrome Web Store
or Google+.
For developers the API is very
simple, one call to pay, one
call to collect.
And last but not least, users
get to make a purchase with
minimal steps.
So how do you get started
with In-App Payments?
Please visit our developers site
below, where you'll find
tutorials and sample code, a
sandbox environment where you
can test the integration of your
app, tools, libraries,
case studies, and more.
Thank you.